Acting is a very safe profession, right?
Well, while it may be thought of as pretty
people playing pretend, it turns out some
movies can actually put their stars in a great
deal of danger!
For this list we are taking a look at some
films where the actors ended up in some pretty
dicey situations.
Enjoy this video and be sure to subscribe
to Screen Rant for more awesome stuff every
day.
Before we start, can you name this movie from
these emojis?
Hang on to your answer and stay tuned for
more fun movie trivia throughout the video.
Here are 10 Popular Movies That Put Actors
In Danger
Now You See Me
The best magic tricks happen when the magician
can fool the audience into thinking there
is actual danger going on.
Unfortunately, the crew behind Now You See
Me needed no tricks as they actually put their
actress, Isla Fisher, in serious danger while
she was performing the underwater escape trick.
The actress nearly drowned filming the stunt
after getting caught up in her submerged chains.
The big problem was that the script also called
for Fisher’s character to pretend like she
was struggling, so it took quite a while for
anyone to realize the actress was in real
danger.
Luckily, Fisher was able to untangle herself
from the chains and escape before things got
dicey.
This was a very dangerous moment and we can
understand why her character had to be recast
for the sequel!
The Hunger Games
The plot of The Hunger Games franchise is
one of the most violent and dangerous stories
of all time so it sort of makes sense that
the production of the films would end up being
rather dangerous too!
Leading lady Jennifer Lawrence did a lot of
her own stunts, which resulted in numerous
scrapes and bruises.
Much worse than that though, was when the
cast had to swim in some very cold and dirty
waters for the second movie.
Several cast members ended up with hard bumps
and ear infections and Lawrence even suffered
a broken eardrum.
The most dangerous moment of all came while
filming the third movie.
In a scene where Lawrence needed to escape
a burning tunnel, a fog machine busted and
the actress ended up inhaling tons of smoke
and passing out.
Luckily, she ended up being fine but we won’t
be surprised if Lawrence sticks to safer roles
going forward!
Lawrence, while still young, has already racked
up quite a bit of success – do you know
how many times she has been nominated for
an Academy Award?
Is it 3, 4 or 5?
Hold on to your answer until the end of the
video!
The Wizard of Oz
The 1939 classic The Wizard of Oz is still
considered one of the greatest movies ever
made.
Hopefully, this long lasting recognition has
helped to offset the truly dangerous working
conditions the actors had to go through to
make this movie.
We get it, it was the 30’s and effects weren’t
as advanced as they are today but it’s pretty
scary to hear about how troubled the production
really was.
The worst part was the makeup that ended up
being so toxic that it burned the faces of
many of the actors including the Wicked Witch
of The West!
If this happened today, it would certainly
cause an enormous legal scandal, as actor’s
looks are some of the most heavily insured
commodities around.
Inglourious Basterds
Quentin Tarantino is a wild man and his movies
reflect his personality as they often feature
some crazy characters and action sequences.
Inglorious Basterds is undoubtedly one of
his best, but it also happens to be one of
his most dangerous.
The climax of the movie comes when Shoshanna
plans to burn down a theater playing Nazi
propaganda film – killing all of the high-ranking
Nazis inside.
To film this scene, Tarantino actually lit
an enormous movie screen on fire, but as you
can imagine things got pretty out of hand.
The flames began to rage out of control, coming
close to burning the cast and crew but Tarantino
couldn’t call cut as they only had one chance
at getting this scene right.
This moment was cinematically brilliant but
we have to wonder if some of the nearly BBQ’d
actors wish it had been done in postproduction.
Mad Max: Fury Road
The practical effects from 2015’s Mad Max:
Fury Road have been praised as being some
of the best of all time, but that acclaim
didn’t come without a cost as director George
Miller put his cast and crew through some
of the most dangerous conditions of all time
in order to create this masterpiece.
First of all, the movie was filmed in the
African desert, where just standing outside
in 150-degree heat could kill someone.
On top of that, the region was well known
for violence with Africa’s various civil
wars making the shoot even more risky.
The action itself was also very dangerous
and stars Tom Hardy and Charlize Theron both
suffered nearly fatal falls from the action.
The movie did turn out amazing it was probably
all worth it but we wonder if a better title
for the film might have been Mad George: Scary
Shoot.
We’ve already told you that this movie was
filmed in Africa but do you know where the
original Mad Max films were shot?
Hang on to your answer until the end of the
video to see how well you know your movies!
The Expendables 3
At this point, you could probably consider
Jason Statham more of a stunt man with dialogue
than an actual actor.
Statham’s brand is synonymous with action
and danger and it’s no surprise that he
keeps popping up in movies like The Expendables,
Mechanic and Furious 7.
While filming the third Expendables, Statham
got into some pretty hot water when he nearly
drowned in the black sea after he crashed
the truck into the water and was trapped inside.
Luckily, the crew was able to pull him out
and Statham didn’t miss a beat – continuing
shooting all of his action scenes.
Jason Statham is one tough guy that we definitely
don’t ever want to fight!
Sylvester Stallone – Rocky IV
Sylvester Stallone is one tough looking dude
so it’s no surprise that while filming Rocky
IV, he actually requested Dolph Lundgren (aka
Ivan Drago) to really try to knock his character
out.
Unfortunately, Stallone isn’t ACTUALLY Rocky
so after Lundgren landed a few serious blow,
Stallone had to call cut to avoid any more
serious injuries.
As it turns out, Sly had put himself in some
pretty serious danger after all and he needed
to be rushed to the hospital as his blood
pressure was spiking to nearly fatal levels.
There’s a reason it’s called acting, and
Stallone definitely learned his lesson that
day.
The Bourne Supremacy
Lately, the most dangerous thing that Matt
Damon can do is go anywhere near Jimmy Kimmel
– as the talk show host will undoubtedly
roast him.
However, it’s not that long ago tha Damon
was one of the most daring action starts working
in Hollywood.
While filming The Bourne Supremacy, Damon
performed all of his own stunts including
some pretty daring underwater drowning scenes
that he was reportedly terrified of doing.
The most dangerous scene from the shoot was
of him smashing another cars together under
tunnel underwater – yikes.
The Bling Ring
Directed by Sofia Coppola, 2013’s The Bling
Ring is probably one of the most dangerously
average movies we’ve seen in a while.
There’s not much that is memorable from
the film but we have to think that Emma Watson
won’t soon forget making the flick, as she
got pretty hurt during the process.
Apparently, while filming a scene at a nightclub
one of the extras stepped on Watson’s toe
with her stiletto heel.
Watson stayed in character and kept on dancing
but when they took a break and the actress
looked down, her foot was bleeding profusely.
Luckily, foot injuries are rarely life threatening
and we are guessing it was the clumsy extra
who probably felt like dying in that moment.
Emma Watson stars in the new live action adaptation
of Beauty and The Beast but do you know what
movie she passed up to play the role of Belle?
Hint: it won some Oscars this year!
The Fifth Wave - Chloe Grace Moretz
For an actress who is only just 20 years young,
Chloe Grace Moretz has already done an impressive
amount of work.
Moretz has unfortunately already suffered
a pretty bad on set injury and while you may
think it came while filming Kick Ass, Chloe
actually got hurt on the set of The Fifth
Wave.
While filming the movie, the then 17-year-old
actress suffered a knee injury that forced
her to wear a brace and walk with crutches.
This slowed down the production big time,
but luckily the actress was able to recover
rather quickly and was able to finish shooting
the movie.
That brings us to the end of our list, which
means it’s time to answer those trivia questions!
Jennifer Lawrence has actually been nominated
for 4 Academy Awards, taking home a win in
2012 for her role in Silver Linings Playbook.
The original Mad Max movies starring Mel Gibson
were filmed in...drum role please…Australia!
And finally, the role that Watson passed up
to play Belle was Mia from 2016’s La La
Land.
She might be regretting that now seeing as
Emma Stone won an Oscar for the role…That’s
all for today make sure you leave us a comment
down below and don’t forget to subscribe
to Screen Rant for more fun videos every day
of the week!